So, let's see if we can figure out how the
distributed loss level cache works. Let's say we have a
processor chip with 16 cores, organized as a four by
four mesh like this. The cores, along with their level
one and level two caches and a slice of L3,
are connected like this. So a single tile here in
this mesh has a core, a level one, level two
cache private to that core, and a slice of the
shared last level, level three cache. And that level three cache is eight
megabytes in size, has a 256-byte block size, is 16-way set associative,
and is distributed among the slices round robin by set number.
If core zero issues a load from address one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight hex, and if this load is a missing level one
and in level two we send the level three request to what tile?